my idea of pizza or something you grab
your fold and your runway your walkway
you could take it to put in your back
pocket innit later
pizzas our way of life it really is it's
a wonderful free way of life till it's
all I've known since I was a little boy
it's all I want to do and I I just love
it
I enjoy New York Pizza going do I say
Chicago people no one if you like a pan
you could put so much stuff into it but
it's not my idea of pizza
my idea of pizza is this there's a long
cooking pie but it's a wonderful pie it
really is and very filling till you
replace in one-third of the water that's
going into flour with foil and that's
what gives you that oily beautiful ready
crush that stays moist that comes up and
that's comes out of Chicago downtown
Chicago 1943 buy pizza jewelry buy a
kilo that no one can dispute it where we
work with our hands they put it in a pan
I feel anybody can make it in a pan the
autumn making it in tossing with your
hand and getting it that thin
that's a big thing well you have to
start with the right mix of everything
you don't which is my sister makes all
that it's an incredible lot if you love
what you do it's gonna bump I love
making pizza I can eat it all day
to this day my father still eats a slice
with anchovies every day wherever they
make good pieces where they make good
people just in Chicago and New York
there's so many places and that's what
stands them apart from the rest if
you're not happy you keep going on the
street till you're get happy are you
ain't gonna go far you're really